Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is about endowing colored images
with depth information, which is typically
done through depth maps.
Depth maps describe how far parts of the scene
are from the camera and are given with a color
coding where the darker the colors are, the
further away the objects are.
These depth maps can be used to apply a variety
of effects to the image that require knowledge
about the distance of the objects within - for
instance, selectively defocusing parts of
the image, or even removing people and inserting
new objects to the scene.
If we, humans look at an image, we have an
intuitive understanding of its contents and
have the knowledge to produce a depth map
by pen and paper.
However, this would, of course, be infeasible
and would take too long, so we would prefer
a machine to do it for us instead.
But of course, machines don’t understand
the concept of 3D geometry so they probably
cannot help us with this.
Or, with the power of machine learning algorithms,
can they?
This new paper from scientists at Google Research
attempts to perform this, but, with a twist.
The twist is that a learning algorithm is
unleashed on a dataset of what they call mannequins,
or in other words, real humans are asked to
stand around frozen in a variety of different
positions while the camera moves around in
the scene.
The goal is that the algorithm would have
a look at these frozen people and take into
consideration the parallax of the camera movement.
This means that the objects closer to the
camera move more than other objects that are
further away.
And turns out, this kind of knowledge can
be exploited, so much so that if we train
our AI properly, it will be able to predict
the depth maps of people that are moving around,
even if it had only seen these frozen mannequins
before.
This is particularly difficult because if
we have an animation, we have to make sure
that the guesses are consistent across time,
or else we get these annoying flickering effects
that you see here with previous techniques.
It is still there with the new method, especially
for the background, but the improvement on
the human part of the image is truly remarkable.
Beyond the removal and insertion techniques
we talked about earlier, I am also really
excited for this method as it may open up
the possibility of creating video versions
of these amazing portrait mode images with
many of the newer smartphones people have
in their pockets.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!